SCP-682 Vs SCP-2617. Could the
icy operatives of the winter
command finally be the ones to take
down the Hard to Destroy Reptile?
SCP-682 was airlifted into the abandoned Russian
village where the 2617 radio tower was situated,
and the Foundation fed the tower the reptile’s
coordinates as it began attacking the village.
2617 generated a large number
of deadly ice warriors,
who took on SCP-682 with both ferocity
and skill, destroying 45% of its body mass
through sustained attacks. It looked like
they might have the lizard on the ropes…
Until it began putting out its own radio waves,
affecting and disrupting the 2617 radio tower,
as well as the researchers in attendance. The
affected personnel, when later interviewed,
were unable to recognize
even the concept of Russia.